well look this is further pressure on so
many families so many working people
um and this wage stagnation has been
going on for 10 years
so i really understand just how people
are struggling it's one of the reasons
that we announced our energy price
freeze yesterday to keep those bills
down and to make the choice that the oil
and gas companies in the north sea
should pay a windfall tax to help people
who are struggling through this winter
period so um it's further evidence i
think of the pressure that so many
millions of people are under but your
plan only looks really ahead to the next
six months this crisis is going to go on
far longer than six months it's nowhere
near enough is it well what we've
addressed is the question of how we deal
with the difficult winter that we're
about to face because those energy price
bills are going to go up from something
in the order of 2000 pounds to 3 500
pounds in october and 4 200 pounds in
january there seems to be a sort of
casual assumption
that most people can cope um but i think
and i'm here at the nationwide in
swindon talking to some of the staff and
they've been very clear that all sorts
of people are coming in for advice
because so many people will not be able
to cope with that so yes this is a
scheme that covers the whole of a very
difficult winter period and for those
that are challenging me um particularly
the tour is challenging me i'd say well
where is your plan for this winter
because there isn't one